wir haben ja live vom staat der falken
haben berichtet der aktuell größten
rakete der welt der absolute wahnsinn
aber es geht noch größer wenn es nach
dem willen von elenas geht die big
felken rocket oder auch big fucking
rocket kurz bfh ist noch mal deutlich
größer und wenn alles klappt soll sich
schon in wenigen jahren die ersten
siedler zum mars bringe ich weiß da gibt
es eine menge fragezeichen aber eines
wurde jetzt beantwortet nämlich wo wie
und warum die bfa hergestellt wird
herzlich willkommen zu den villen mass
chroniken bei klick zum science fiction
vielen dank und wenig meint für den
themenvorschlag ich erinnere mich noch
wie steve jobs die pläne für das neue
apple hauptquartier den lokalen
politikerinnen und politikern
vorgestellt hat und was für ein
unglaubliches gebäude da dann entstanden
ist genau so ist es jetzt auch in los
angeles passiert nicht ihnen macht
selbst aber seine verantwortlichen
manager haben großes vor und jetzt die
genehmigung dafür von lokalen politik
bekommen es wird eine riesige fabrik und
das im hafen von los angeles
denn mit dem bau der bfa werden
vollkommen neue dimensionen der
raumfahrt erreicht und da stoßen die
entwicklungsteams an ihre grenzen und
zwar an transport grenzen
die neue riesige rakete wird nämlich
voraussichtlich die größe her bis größte
bisher überhaupt hergestellte rakete und
das hat konsequenzen
sie kann nämlich nicht mehr irgendwo
produziert werden eine solch riesiger
rakete und auch nur teile von ihr können
nicht mehr über land transportiert
werden straßen sind dafür einfach zu
schmal und zu klein es gibt nur eine
möglichkeit um die raketenteile
auszuliefern und gelandete stufen wieder
in die fabrik zurück zu transportieren
die fabrik muss sich in einem hafen
befinden deshalb hat spacex jetzt einen
ziemlich großen teil des hafens von los
angeles gepachtet für 0 dollar
20 jahre muss das unternehmen nichts
bezahlen dafür baut es auf dem gelände
eine riesige halle in der die raketen
montiert werden sollen schon bis zum
ende des jahres soll die fabrik fertig
sein denn noch dieses jahr sollen die
ersten versuche mit der bfh staaten laut
was soll die letzte stufe also die
spitze der rakete mit hopper flüge
getestet werden dabei wird das schiff
mehrere kilometer in die atmosphäre
geschossen und wieder gelernt maskat
bisher keine zeitpläne mehr für mögliche
mission zum mars bekannt gegeben da ist
inzwischen vorsichtig geworden aber die
ersten tests in erd orbit sollen in drei
bis vier jahren beginnen also eine
mars-mission schon 2022 jetzt schon mal
angekündigt hatte ist so nicht mehr
machbar
das ist auch kein wunder denn die bfh
ist wirklich eine ganz neue
herausforderung werden die völker 9 noch
22 8 tonnen in die niedrige
erdumlaufbahn bringen konnte waren es
bei der falcon heavy mit 63,8 tonnen
schon drei mal so viel
aber die big fate locken soll bis zu 250
tonnen in eine niedrige umlaufbahn
bringen
zehnmal so viel wie die felgen ein der
absolute wandeln es wird also spannend
wie schnell jetzt alles geht mit der
neuen fabrik sind jedenfalls die besten
voraussetzungen geschaffen
ja und jetzt muss ich mal eine lanze für
maniac brechen sein kann als flips mit
allem über filme serien und genc die
macht dann zusammen mit bad und die
kennen sich wirklich unglaublich gut aus
also nicht das abo mit der von flitz
vergessen also mit der glocke dafür hier
draufklicken meine absolute empfehlung
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken live erster staat der welt
in heavy das ist wirklich absolute
gänsehaut wie das da abgelaufen ist
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran